we're gonna turn now to weather where
ted is bringing some uh thanksgiving and
christmas cheer yeah i think we've kind
of skipped through thanksgiving already
no no no no no no no no
i'm out here i have not had any stuffing
or turkey or mashed potatoes or pie yet
i don't want to skip through
thanksgiving well it just feels like
we've jumped right into
santa time
we're not going to fast forward
thanksgiving we're going to enjoy it
hey guys yeah i feel like i'm at
disneyland the music's pumped up you can
hear the holiday music down here where
i'm at is downtown summerlin for their
annual holiday parade it kicks off today
and this is really interesting because
last year we were this was canceled look
at all the people down here they're so
excited to see this parade back in
action again look at all the smiles on
everyone's faces now the parade just
started at six o'clock so eric's zooming
in you can see the beginning of the
parade the floats have begun everyone's
excited to see this people came as early
as four o'clock today to see this parade
we're going to show you this parade also
on the end of this
a-block and also during my main weather
as well currently outside we want to
show you the conditions at this hour
before we come back out to this right
now temperatures are nice and cool
people are bundled up with good reason
yesterday we didn't even reach 70. that
was the case again for the day today
wind speeds are light and that's great
you don't want that big windshield down
here you don't want it chilly down here
with those winds as far as your evening
planet goes and looking good
temperatures of course this evening are
going to be chilly bundle up for tonight
winds stay light tonight but we'll keep
around those high clouds as you see all
the way through this evening joining us
8 news now 11 will be at 55 degrees back
live now as you can see there are nine
floats this is float number one santa's
gonna be coming at the last one and
finale of this and of course there is
going to be snow yes it's going to snow
in downtown summerlin
and i am forecasting it it's gonna
happen
we'll see you again in just a few
minutes reporting live ted florendo live
local now